I've never pretended to be a police  officer  right and and I've never I've never  threatened a shootout with the police  correctly respond to that and you know  what's so funny I am with many police  officers and at the same time Mr Walker  Mr Walker Mr Walker excuse me Mr Walker  anyway  I need to let you know Mr Walker you are  very well aware of the rules tonight yes  and you have a prop that is not allowed  sir I ask you to put that prop away well  there's not a problem this is real and  he said I have a problem  Mr Walker excuse me sir yes you're very  well aware of the rules aren't you well  are you aware of being brought up the  truth let's talk about the truth thank  you for putting that prop away and as a  matter of fact we still have a lot to  get to